அது வயதுக்குப் பிறகு எனக்கு எங்கே யாரும் அந்த விஷயத்தைச் சொன்னவில்லை.
அது அந்த வயதில் என் மனத்தில் பொய் சொல்லக்கூடாது பதி வைக்கத்துக்காகச் சொன்ன விஷயம்.
அவ்வளவுதான், எறுப்பு தின்னா கண்டு தெரியும் அப்படின்னு சொல்வார்.
அதை எங்கள் வீட்டில் எங்கள் அப்பா கோலம் போடும்போது மாம் கோலம் போட்டுவிட்டு எறுப்பு அதை தின்னத்தால் நமக்கு அது வெறும் மூக்க வைத்துதான் வாழ்கிறது.
முகர் சக்தி அதுக்கு கண் தெரியாது. அப்படியென்று நமக்கு நம்பிக்க.
அந்த இரும்புக்கு நாம் சாப்பார் போட்டால் நமக்கு கண் தெரியும் கர்மம். நிறைய சிறிய வயதில் சில விஷயத்தைப் பதிவைக்கச் சொல்லிருக்கிறார்கள். அது சின்டிப்பிக்க அப்படியென்று தெரியாது.
ஆனால் சின்ன வயதில் சமுதாயத்தில் மக்கள் மனத்தில் சந்தேவையில் அப்படியிருக்கிறது.
நீங்கள் ஒரு விஷயம் சொல்லுங்கள். நன்றாக இருக்கும்.
இன்னும் இப்போது சொல்ல வேண்டுமா என்று தெரியவில்லை. நாலாது கேள்வியும் மிகவும் சுத்தம்.
அதாவது இந்த கர்மா என்பது எப்போது பதிலாக இருக்கும் என்று சொல்லலாம்.
கர்மாவின் தெரியவில் தெரியவில் தெரியவில் தெரியவில் தெரிய
தெரியவில் தெரியவில் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும்.
தெரியவில் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும்.
தெரியவில் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும் தெரியவில் பதிலாக இருக்கும்.